after the very first one of those
massive marches i was walking down
the finchley road with my daughter and a
convoy of cars with palestinian flags
with a megaphone were screaming out rape
jewish women and raped their daughters
my daughter walks on that route for
school every day and said was so upset
and distressed and was saying you know
my you know days after weeks after you
know mummy what does this mean am i
going to be raped
that was done in the name of palestinian
activism
welcome to marshall matters with me
winston marshall where i look into the
creative industries
and what topics can and can't be talked
about in this day and age today i feel
very lucky to be joined by actress and
writer tracy ann obermann tracy ann is a
stalwart of british television and has
performed in such classics as doctor who
eastenders the tracy allman show ricky
gervais's afterlife and one of my
all-time favorites toast of london as
mrs purchase
that is to name but a few
host of the troll podcast and until
recently believed i believe a lifetime
member of the labour party tracy anne
has become an activist on the issue of
anti-semitism in the party but also
within the film industry tracianne thank
you so much for joining me
thank you for having me winston and
you're are you in london at the moment
i am i am in london yeah
we haven't really traveled out i haven't
traveled out other than for work since
some since uh locked down the first
lockdown right which is difficult
because we normally travel quite a lot
yeah because you were due to do a
touring
uh show is that right of of uh yeah and
we were meant to be taking that abroad
as well at some point of the merchant of
venice and also um you know sort of
filming abroad i have been working but
it's all been in england and
we come a lot to la uh
for work and um that's been off the
cards as well i'm so sorry it must be
very frustrating
yeah where did your passion for acting
come from you're born and raised in
london right and and yeah and i was
raised in north london and my family uh
you know were working class immigrants
uh jewish you know came in from the east
end um and we moved out to uh north
london
the very far end of the jubilee line and
i i think um
shelly winters always said i always
remember saying this that when you're
born a fairy goes over your crib and
says you shall be a doctor you shall be
a dentist you should be an accountant
you should be a nurse and she always
said if you're really really unlucky
that fairy will say you shall be an
actress i do think that that was it was
something that i was born um knowing
that i wanted to do i think it is
vocational um but my family were you
know saying you wanted to be an actor
or anything creative was like saying you
wanted to be an astronaut it was what
are you talking about you know who's an
actor
an actress nobody does that how do you
make a living
what sort of what sort of background
were they professionally speaking what
kind of background what were they um
great grandparent who i was very close
to uh when i was brought up they came
more from the kind of um
the schmutter business you know the sort
of uh
that kind of working class stalls
bringing in fabrics selling it in fact
my great my grandfather always said that
they were the first people to bring in
jeans into the to this country and they
sold them on their market store but then
i've subsequently gathered that
everybody's jewish grandfather said that
they were the first people that would
leave jeans i think it was um or
uh and my dad you know again when you
come from those sort of immigrant
backgrounds they they work their asses
off to give their kids an education my
dad then became a lawyer um and always
hated it and wanted to be a footballer
but uh and and then
i be i was the anomaly and rather than
go into a secure profession became an
actress and i'm reclaiming that word
winston actress
yeah because dorothy parker always said
scratch an actor and you get an actress
and i think that is true we're all
actresses
so um your
your family were in the fabric industry
and uh and but also
right your
great-grandmother
uh was on uh uh in the east end when
mosley's black shirts were
um uh marching and she uh stood uh uh up
against them is that is that is that
right am i getting the story that's true
that absolutely is true ridley road is a
bbc one um he's a bbc one four-part
drama that i think is now out in america
and has been bought globally and it
it tells the story of um
1960 the 1960s the 62 group which was a
bunch of east end
jewish um activists and actually it went
across the country uh because oswald
mosley who had been an anti-um jewish
fascist uh leader who could have been
the leader of the labour party um
marched on the east end was very good
friends with hitler uh and in fact got
married to his second wife diana cooper
diana mitford um at goebbels house with
hitler as a witness you know the british
as much as they try and ignore their
fascist past have had a great flirtation
with fascism um particularly amongst the
aristocracy actually at times of of
great uh chaos and and and and potential
unease
so yes i came from a family my
great-grandmother stood uh against with
all the other working-class communities
of that east end um cable street march
which was fighting the jewish entity uh
the jewish um the zionist uh
enemy
uh judah perished judah and ridley road
under um took that to the 1960s and what
this country has forgotten is that in
1962 there was an enormous rise of
fascism under a man called colin jordan
who was an acolyte of mosley
and he um so soon after the holocaust
with british troops that had liberated
those camps uh where you know six
million jews had been gas murdered
mutilated many of some of whom were my
family and many other people's families
um he marched
across the country against against the
the jewish entity again and perished
judah and
in the east end of london they were
burning synagogues they were attacking
jews and the worrying thing in the 60s
was there was very little help from the
authorities the police weren't that
interested um mps weren't that
interested in the very authorities that
should have been protecting uh this this
group actually didn't and so the jewish
um
sort of working-class community took it
into their own hands to look after their
own and they set up the 62 group and
they were like a vigilante group that
would had infiltrated um colin jordan's
organization they would find out where
the marches were happening they will
find out when they were attacking the
synagogues where they were burning the
jewish you know jewish people i think
one boy was killed and they would
actively go out on the streets and fight
violence with violence and what was so
um interesting about this series is that
this is a jewish archetypal character
that we don't really see
tell me if i'm talking too much
which is the archetypal character well
you know we're used to seeing
particularly in britain in our
archetypes of jewish characters of fagin
um from you know oliver twist uh or is
[ __ ] that you know my duck it's my
daughter and also we uh holocaust
victims or um the american version which
is the nerdy jewish man and the jewish
american princess these are the
archetypes of characters that we see but
here in ridley road with sexy
exciting um empowered fighting
working-class jews who weren't victims
um and who didn't and who didn't
um
you know who stood up and empowered
themselves and it's not not jewish
characters we're used to seeing
inglorious bastards come to mind as
another version of that um
that changing of the archetype one of my
favorite films yeah absolutely
inglorious bastards totally did that and
and it's so powerful because exactly
that we're not victims we're more than
just being seen in concentration camps
and we're more than just being seen as
doctors i mean it's you know this whole
idea of jewface as well and jewish
characters sarah silverman's been
talking about that is it sarah silverman
or
sarah silverman has been talking about
that a lot recently saying you know why
is it that the jewish character or the
jewish actress
is
either the pushy best friend the
neurotic mother she never leads a
narrative she's not seen as a romantic
lead there's a lot of nega and if if
there is such a jewish character she's
invariably played by somebody who isn't
jewish so um i think that there's a lot
of very interesting debate around do
face at the moment as well
which has come out of is it if it's not
right to blackface and it's not right to
yellow face and you know if trans actors
are being played by
um anyone other than trans actors why i
think the same respect and debate has to
be put around jewish characters too
and so the
is the answer to that to write more or
have more uh
films and stories
where those those uh uh
old archetypes are pushed aside and new
archetypes are
written what or or what what do you
think's a way for what what do you want
to see from your industry in that's in
that sense you know it's funny i'm you
know i am a working you know i'm an
actress and i'm a writer i'm a creative
and i i've found myself again and again
at the forefront of this debate being
very vocal about it
and i found myself becoming more of a
spokesman and it makes me you know it's
interesting that that's the position
that i found myself in that so few
people
have talked about this in our industry
i think the answer is to when you're i
think we have to look for more
interesting jewish stories i think we
have to have um more debate about who
represents those stories who are the
writers who are the producers who has
the right to appropriate that look as an
actor we can you know as an actor you
can play anything that's the whole thing
about acting and the industry i think is
boxing itself in more and more in that
maybe
you know if you can only act what you
are then that does that become
documentary and less about the art of
acting i think what david bedeal so
brilliantly said in his book and i think
it's something that he and i have felt
for a very long time is if every other
minority
in this period of time is being given
the respect in the industry of
cultural appropriation who can play them
sensitivity the same and the stories
that are being told the same has to be
done for
jewish characters and jewish stories so
yes we have to find more interesting
stories more varied stories and more
ways of challenging the
anti-jewish tropes and archetypes that
we're used to seeing
on on the sort of issue of of of being
jewish in the film industry you said
some some uh
uh quite striking things um which which
actually is one of the
um in any exploring the issues that we
can and can't talk about
um i think you said
jewish performers are feeling
particularly unsafe at the moment
and i think you said that in summer 2021
and and is i mean is that
a separate issue i think that that might
have been in in
reaction to
equity the trade union uh for actors and
actresses um uh uh them
in support of bds or if it wasn't bds
specifically it was a line against
israel
am i getting this right or um it's look
this is it you know this is a really
nuanced and difficult thing in my
opinion and many other people's opinion
equity is the actors union it has a very
broad range of actors that it is meant
to work with
in the time of um incredible insecurity
for actors where theaters and films went
down where all of us are self-employed
where most actors were just worried
about where the next you know meal check
was coming in
it was not up to equity or their leaders
to
make a very strong stand on
um calling for sanctions against israel
you know you can be as critical of
israel as you like there is it is a very
complicated and nuanced geopolitical
situation but absolutely hold that
government to account
however what you don't have the right to
do when you are running a union is to
ignore every other issue but to become
obsessed about one issue so when the the
um the president and the general
secretary of um equity
called for their members to go on a
sanctioning israel march
what they were sanctioning
uh what they were actually sanctioning
themselves was to march
with people who the week before and the
week before had been holding up the most
horrible anti-semitic banners they were
seen stan you know these people were
standing in in support for palestinian
rights and absolutely we support that
but what you can't do is hide your
palestinian activism under
anti-semitism so
you can't ask for your people to go on a
march next to people that were holding
up banners of hitler um of of um
of hitler as in a pistol saying hitler
was right you can't ask your people to
go on a march with a woman a politician
who called for an interfather on the
streets of london
which effectively is calling for death
to jews on the streets of london you
can't ask your membership to support and
go on a march with a big picture of um
jesus being nailed to a cross with they
did it to him don't let them do it again
i mean these are repulsive anti-semitic
tropes and i have to tell you winston
after the very first one of those
massive marches i was walking down um
the finchley road with my daughter and a
convoy of cars with palestinian flags
with a megaphone were screaming out
rape jewish women and rape their
daughters my daughter walks on that
route for school every day and said was
so upset and distressed and was saying
you know my you know for days after
weeks after you know mummy what does
this mean am i gonna be raped
that was done in the name of palestinian
activism
and um another example is recently
around north london in jewish areas
convoys driving through jews being
attacked there was a big after that
march that equity had endorsed a large
group of men were wandering around the
streets of knightsbridge looking for
jews to kill zionists to attack this is
a march that equity were endorsing their
members to go on equity have have put
out 24 statements about israel
when i looked through their list they'd
done nothing on any other
complicated
geopolitical situation uyghurs
myanmar rohingyas nothing so then one
has to say this is the obsession of
certain people in the leadership so
it led me to realize that if they're
prepared to endorse that
a lot of jewish actors then spoke to me
and said you know when i go into a
rehearsal room and i've got my morgan
david on show the minute i go into a
rehearsal room i tuck it in i don't want
anybody to know i'm jewish why don't you
want anybody to know you're jewish
because i don't want to immediately have
to get into a political purity test
about israel i don't want to get asked
have you been to israel are you a
zionist what's your position on israel
how do you feel about the palestinians
similarly friends of mine who come from
other cultures iranian chinese um you
know muslim they're never put in a
position
of having to go through a political
purity test and so that's what i felt so
strongly about and then found myself on
newsnite and other
programs flagging up the fact that
behind the scenes many many people were
calling equity out and saying how
disgusting it was that they had endorsed
this but worse than that but they
weren't prepared to put their head above
the parapet and say it but worse than
that equity doubled down on it they sort
of went
you know
you can be a member here if you're a
certain type of jew with a certain type
of politics uh and
we're not we're not overly apologetic to
anyone who feels that they're sort of
oppressed
in
a rehearsal room or in a work situation
why won't they put their heads above the
parapet what why why because a lot of
people are scared i when i first started
you know
we're going about this but when i when i
first you know i when when jeremy corbyn
was elected as the leader of the labour
party
a lot of people thought that
he was um
a positive and uh you know change is
coming was their motto
and the longer that jeremy corbyn was in
power as the leader
more and more and more about him his
associations his affiliations
and um his
problem
in my opinion with allowing
anti-semitism to flourish in the labour
party without really coming down hard on
it became more apparent
now this is up for debate but when you
have a leader who cannot see a problem
in endorsing a mural that effectively
looks like a nazi propaganda mural with
jewish bankers pushing down on the heads
of the workers and ought to have that
mural that have been painted on a wall
in east london i think
allowed to stay up when you have got
when you don't have a problem with a man
who was present but not involved in a
wreath-laying um
exercise uh for
the palestinian um liberation
with terrorists who you know what this
is all very difficult because he's
starting to sue you know in my opinion
sorry winston it's difficult don't don't
before i started speaking out um against
the labour party when i could see lots
of anti-semitism casual anti-semitism
misogyny and effectively racism being
allowed to pass under the banner of
uh of labor so when i go to glastonbury
and i see posters
um three massive posters talking about
the rothschild entity and how all evils
come from the rothschilds and this is in
areas that i should be feeling at home
and comfortable an alarm bell starts to
ring because talking about the
rothschilds entity and zionist
conspiracies and jewish banking control
goes back to exactly what the nazis said
in the 20s and 30s and
we know what the end game of that is i
know what the endgame of that is you
know when i was four years old my
parents took me to the holocaust museum
in in israel i was far too young but i
you know i was watching and saw
the end game of other the end game of
jew hate the end game of racism piles of
bodies children's shoes hair
um
you know my
we spent a day with my father looked up
in the hall of names to see what had
happened to to our family um
you know i
so many of us were watching um a woman
who spray-painted the warsaw ghetto wall
with the words free gaza being invited
to the labour party conference to speak
and that was the moment where i flipped
because my family didn't die in the
warsaw ghetto because of israel there
was no israel there was no homeland and
there was no gaza they were gas-murdered
tortured experimented on for being
jewish and if your family's open grave
had been spray painted and defaced i
would like to think that that person
wouldn't be giving a given a legitimate
platform
and this idea that somehow jews don't
count um
because
uh
we aren't seen you know we're white
enough to pass we're seen as rothschild
economically secure
all these different things
i just couldn't keep silent anymore and
so i sat in the car
and i put out a tweet
that said i'm very upset that this woman
who spray-painted my family's open grave
has been invited and legitimized
to come to my momentum to come to the
labour party to talk
and um the hatred that i got back from
labour party members from socialists
from
some mps from some
councillors
was unbelievable i sat in a car while a
rolling screed of hate came my way
every member of your family deserve to
die to atone for one palestinian's death
if all your family died in the holocaust
why are you still here the numbers don't
add up the hollow hoax is nonsense
um uh prove us prove to us that your
family were in the warsaw ghetto um the
warsaw ghetto is nothing compared to
gaza that was one i got which was like
yeah gaza's hell
really hell but it it is not the warsaw
ghetto um
so and the comparable is a force
comparable so i'm ranting at you now
winston but it touched a nerve and it i
looked around for grown-ups to come into
this debate to say
this is holocaust denial
jeremy corbyn has associated with people
who are holocaust deniers he calls
himself a man of peace and yet he
invites terrorists
from terrorist organizations for tea in
parliament but refuses and no platforms
all israelis you can't call yourself a
man of peace if you're already prepared
to talk to one side of an equation
and i think that unfortunately jeremy's
blind spot jeremy corbyn's blind spot
when it came to what he saw as
his work for palestinian activism often
bled into anti-semitism and allowed
anti-semitism to flourish
and
that was the problem with left-wing
anti-semitism is that the left say but
we are the good guys we are anti-racist
therefore we can't be anti-semitic
and i think that is something that
myself and david deal and others have
have had to challenge to say we are of
the left but you are being anti-semitic
and it counts because you are like you
are a lifetime labour party member is
that correct or well my
great-grandparents in the east end were
you know they they were communists they
come over from from belarus where
the pogroms were happening you know
my great-grandmother
who i've basically i'm doing this merch
into venice later on um next year i
based my [ __ ] on on her this these
tough
tough jewish woman that saw her was
nearly raped when she was 14 in belarus
nearly saw her father being beheaded um
sar nicholas the second was virulently
anti-jewish he made all the jews live in
what was known as the pale of
settlements which was a sort of peasant
living a bit you know when you look at
anatheka and fiddler on the roof that my
great-grandmother's
grandmother always used to say that's a
documentary because that was how they
lived
and she was sent out at 14 on a boat on
her own to survive these pogroms and
arrived in england
met her future husband on the boat he
was a staunch um anti-czarist they were
for workers rights they were for the the
universal uh dignity and and rights for
for all workers um their judaism in many
ways was second to their politics and
they came into the east end and they
helped form the labour party so the
labour party
um
you know i feel is in me and was part of
me and then to feel that i didn't have a
place in that labour party because i was
being told by ken livingston that
basically all jews are rich well i know
loads of non
jews who aren't rich all jews are you
know part of a global zionist conspiracy
what are you talking about hitler said
that and then when he went even further
and said that um that the the zionists
had i think he went on lbc
when i heard ken livingston say
hitler was a zionist until he went mad
and murdered six million of them
which was offensive on so many levels
and jeremy corbyn's labour party were
not really prepared to do anything about
that that was the moment that i knew i
didn't really have a place in the legal
party anymore so where does that leave
you politically look
as you yourself know we are living in
very divisive times
and i think to speak out is brave
because
as you and i both know we could lose our
livelihoods we work in an industry that
is cautious and tends to go with the
flow of what is
popularly seen as the correct
way to talk
because nobody wants to lose their
jobs and i think that that was the risk
that i took in speaking out
against
you know saying i don't think jeremy
corbyn is everything that my industry
is saying that he is i don't think he's
this kindly man i think there's many
facets here that that worry me about him
and i have to say
whilst it was brave i ended up taking a
lot of people with me and after the
election and when more and more things
came out about jeremy and
who he was and what he stood for and his
position on brexit and
many many things as well as the
anti-semitism
that seemingly flourished and the
attacks that people like myself were
getting online
by his
online hate army
some of which seem to come from
organized groups within
momentum or labor hq i don't know
whether that's true but um
it became very difficult i mean the hate
that i've received on the back of this
is ridiculous myself and um
a television uh presenter rachel riley
uh have had so much abuse over the years
because we were two jewish women
who in the ad absence of anyone from the
labour party or anyone else putting
their heads and speaking out loud about
it we ended up becoming the sort of
figureheads for that and the misogyny
and anti-semitism that rolled into this
hate
was quite remarkable you know we've been
called pedophiles grooming pedophiles i
was told that you know i i'm i'm being
paid by the israeli government i work
for a foreign operative
the best one was oh that i'm a tax
evading [ __ ] a tax evading rothschild
[ __ ]
that i have a this one was weird that i
have a castle in the de doing never even
been there winston where i hide my tax
evading jew money and that's why i
didn't want to support jeremy corbyn
and this leads us on to the next thing
which is i was always taught that when a
minority
tell you that they're feeling
oppressed hurt got at
um marginalized abused
you listen to them you don't try and
interpret it
and what has happened more and more with
jewish people is right from the
beginning when we went oh
that is anti-semitic
that is wrong you can't really say that
we were told
oh shut up the reason that you're saying
that is because a b c and d yeah they
talk about anti-semitism but what they
mean is a b c and d we i myself and many
others are constantly being told that
what we really mean is
and that's wrong
yeah and actually there's a scene in in
uh ridley roe where you your character
and the black character uh come together
and say aren't we fighting the same
fight something along those lines which
i think challenges
on amani who adapted the book that scene
was very important to her and i think it
is important because
my character nancy
who's a sort of female sort of de facto
leader of of the 62 group the um stevie
the mixed race boy comes in and says i
just met your husband in prison
and she says to him
um we're we're fighting the same we've
got the same fight and he says no it's
not the same fight but
you know maybe
the feeling is the same something like
that oh no that's right she says our
experiences are the same and he says no
our experiences aren't the same but
we're fighting the same people and i
want what i really wish at this time is
that all
it seems to me that so many minority
groups are playing um
are fighting each other whereas really
we should be pulling together and when i
think of the grand tradition of the
black and jewish community standing
together
um against apartheid civil rights in
america
racism in this country
there is a long long tradition of those
communities being allies and friends and
somewhere along the line that's been
forgotten and i think we should remind
ourselves that we are standing together
rather than having to pull chunks of
each other
um there's something that you said
earlier which i'm just not sure i've
understood quite right but i was asking
about the film industry and what kind of
company said and then we we
moved to
uh corbyn's labour party and it
would it be is there
speaking out against
the labour party or against corbyn did
that have repercussions within the film
industry
yeah i thought it would um because very
much at that time within my industry
there was a lot of support for jeremy
corbyn and people didn't want to be told
or to be challenged on why there were
lots of very worrying things and
associations about him and the people
that he surrounded himself by and so i
did take a risk
um and
i was very nervous that i would get
cancelled because of it but you know
they winston they say activists are born
not made and sometimes you feel that
your need to speak out for people
who are frightened to do it
was stronger than the need to protect my
career
um so no on the contrary when i did
start speaking out i actually found the
support that i was getting was
unbelievable
uh you know casting directors other
actors writers writing to me going i've
wanted to say this for so long and i'm
really scared to do it but thank you for
having the balls to do it and then and
then slowly but surely more and more
people started to check what the
temperature was
and as more things were being reported
and they were looking at it through
a different
a wider perspective rather than just an
echo chamber
i think i took them with me and i've
been
humbled and amazed at how much support i
have got
i've had for it and i think courage
calls to courage everywhere and i think
that's what's what happened with me how
how was it for you
um
i've certainly had a lot of uh
support um and uh a lot of private
messages but
um of support of support which is which
has given me much um
much comfort um and
i do think that some of these i do think
it's the duty of people in in positions
of of leadership or people like um
yourself who have who have uh
achieved so much and and are really
leaders in in the industry because it's
the people who
uh who are much lower in the hierarchy
so to speak or uh you know who have a
lot more uh stake and and and if they
lose
their role or their job
you know they lose it all and i think
that the those of us at the top should
be the ones to be more vocal so i think
there's a sense of i do see a sense of
duty in that respect
um
but
what what happened to you what what was
what was the situation if you don't i
mean you can cut this out but remind me
again what actually happened that ended
up with you
so i was through the pandemic tweeting
about uh books i was reading
and
tweeted uh about a book critical of
far-left extremism in the u.s so pretty
niche for a londoner
and i really didn't have a big following
at all i think i only had a few thousand
follow me and and this tweet blew up
exploded
and um
ended
being in a position where because i'm
not a alone
actor i'm not a
i was with the band so they were getting
all this abuse as a consequence of me of
my my tweet
that
i was in this position where
i could i'd either have to lie to
protect them so that they wouldn't have
the abuse or
tell the truth but remove myself so as
so they didn't have to face the the
abuse
um which
i think is ridiculous that
you know that a book can do that but
nevertheless
uh you know uh i think one has to stick
with one's one's beliefs and and it's
been a very difficult period but
as i said people have come out in in
support and and uh
uh i do think that certain issues need a
critical mass and and
um people can
you know speak about it more i think
watching you on anti-semitism has been a
really good example of that i remember
in
summer 2020 i think
in the music industry
uh it was uh the the black square blm
everything uh blm kind of taken uh it
was capture the imagination of everyone
it was the number one issue and i
remember at the same time
uh you had people in the musical street
uh i remember ice cube posting the mere
one mural that you referenced earlier
and then there was the wily
rant which i know you've spoken about
and actually i know people that were
individually called out in that right
and were terrified for their lives
literally terrified for their lives and
all this was happening and
i i found it very
uh
confusing to be
in a situation where racism was the
number one issue but this particular
type of racism
was not
given even nearly
the same kind of uh attention so i led i
led uh the kind of no safe space for do
hate on on twitter i i weirdly for
whatever it did um i you know i was so
horrified by the right wiley thing and i
was so angry that this man had been
allowed for 248 hours to tweet the most
repulsive anti-semitism uh
just non-stop non-stop to the point that
i ended up speaking to the ceo of
twitter and um anyway so uh to say you
know if you're monetized by hate and
that's how you monetize your site be
honest about it and they took you know
so basically we did a two-day walk-out
we did a 48 hours of of walking out with
no safe space for do hate we know we
came out with with with our logos and
unbelievably we got we had a really
really good support for it however wise
it was whatever it managed to achieve
but i tell you what it did manage to
achieve again it managed to achieve ma
it got all the way up to parliament
where uh the
pretty patel and boris johnson were
talking about it it got it was part of i
think informing the online hate bill
that's hopefully going through
it absolutely made it to every single
news channel um it got me talking to uh
the heads of twitter who said absolutely
we do not uh monetize by hate and they
barred him he then moved on to instagram
where he then did four days of videos of
non-stop do hate uh and again we did the
48-hour ban there too
um and
we we you know we
my argument with those social media
companies were particularly with
instagram is if you can take a picture
of a woman breastfeeding off your site
because it's deemed offensive how have
you let a man with effectively between
twitter and instagram with a million
followers give him a platform and a
megaphone to scream out his
jewish hate which was beyond belief
um and
if
you do that for monetized clicks because
it gets you followers and it gets people
on your platform then you have to be
open about it no no no no absolutely not
and they removed him
he then moved on to facebook where he
then did another four days of ranting
about jews and then they removed him
from that and i think because i'm i'm i
started that because i was so angry for
exactly that reason which is you can't
be flagging up um you know you it's it's
brilliant that blm and blackout tuesday
became a thing but you can't let a man
sit for six days spewing out how jews
are the root of all evil and the most
money obsessed devils in the world and
hitler had a reason for not liking them
that's that's crazy so we got a lot of
support for that and it just takes
people to turn around and go this is
unacceptable
no
jews do count
yeah absolutely well thank goodness we
have brave people like yourself
doing that and and hopefully meaning
that
uh you know that
this kind of start well this stuff
doesn't continue to happen although
uh i'm pessimistic and i think that it
will continue to happen but um
uh at least it's being called out and
and also one thing i would say winston
and and this is the thing that i'm most
pleased about is i was one of the few
jewish people early doors that were
prepared to stand up and go yes i am
jewish i'm not going to hide it and i'm
proud of my heritage and i'm calling out
what is wrong and as much hate as you
throw at me because i'm a woman you
think i'm going to disappear from these
social media media sites because i want
to be light and as an
actress i want to be light and be
decorative
and i didn't and many other women then
wrote to me and went wow you know
watching you has made me feel brave
enough to speak out to my boss at work
my boyfriend you i felt empowered and i
think we can't be what we can't see so
once we see people turning around and
going you know what [ __ ] it this is
wrong nobody else may be calling it out
but i'm prepared to do it i think it
give and and i and i'm still standing
and still working more than ever i think
it does make other people braver
and i'm sorry that you had to
you felt you had to leave mumford
because
i think that's wrong people are allowed
to have diverse opinions
uh it's interesting you say that with
with
in the entertainment industry you're
right it one needs to be liked that is
one sort of uh
trade like well it's not that
you know everyone there's a lot of
talent you're a talented actress and and
you need to
hone your craft etc but what you trade
off is your likability so you're putting
yourself a tremendous risk
for your for your uh business uh in in
taking that stance
um and but how great to hear that it
hasn't actually
had
an impact no and i think it's better to
be respected than liked
i think people respect i think
likability is i don't even know what
that even means why do we have to be
liked
you just have to be true to yourself i
think when i think when people find when
people are able to this sounds so wanky
but if you are your own best friend and
your own cheerleader and you and you
really stand by what your bottom lines
and your truths are
able to change your opinion able to hear
other points of view able to hear debate
but if you really stand for something
you can't be cancelled
and you take other people with you and
i hope one day you you know i hope you
you do go back because i looked at you
and thought
how you know you're allowed to tweet out
that you liked a book that other people
disagreed with you are allowed to do
that and i couldn't understand the
backlash but the anger and the fury that
social media manages to whip up
and the power i do think the power of of
social media is waiting though and i
think those online
hate mobs that that pile on i think the
power is waning and i think that has
reached its critical mass i think the um
the
you know
as a very wise uh rabbi sachs once said
anti-semitism
is not about jews it's about a sickness
in society and a greater sickness and
from it's what starts with the jews
never ends with jews and i think if we
allow jew hate to flourish in any
society all other evils follow
does your to your point about um uh
you know respecting yourself and and and
um uh being a piece of yourself and this
is a perhaps a well this is certainly a
personal question so you don't have to
go there but does your jewish faith uh
lead you in in that respect or or does
i don't know if it's the faith i know
that there's something happened to me
when i was four and i went to the
holocaust museum and i remember looking
around and feeling so overwhelmed by
what this what what i was seeing that
this was something about being jewish
this was that all these people had put
in so much work and effort to make this
this this death machine you know after
my uncle who survived uh you know always
said to me you know you've got to
remember you had engineers coming in
every day to mend those gas chambers you
had um engineers coming in to mend the
machines that used to frank the you know
the germanic uh
brilliant industrialization of that
genocide was you know took people to
manage it so you know um it just takes
good people to look away for evil to
flourish and i think that was the main
thing that i took was that
that if i
as as much as the shame and that feeling
of why do people hate jews so much that
they were prepared to build this this
death machine and why were they prepared
to do all of these things over all these
centuries but if i've survived and i'm
part of a against all the odds of
surviving then i have a duty to stand up
and call out all forms of bullying
racism and anti-semitism
yeah absolutely and i suppose social
media
is is the one of the ways to do that i
guess so and and so you're going to keep
getting abuse right if the you know in
continuing to use it that abuse
yeah i was i was put on on twitter uh
when i was doing a film with um omega
lily and uh and and david badil and and
david schneider and they said you're
gonna love this site so i was on it i
was quite an early adopter 2009 it was
very it was very funny it was very witty
you know you'd be sitting there watching
bake off with stephen fry and mia farrow
it was it was cute it was you know it
was it was fun it was weird you could it
was kind of it was like being at a
really funny witty party
and then and i never received a single
bit of abuse a lot of friends it was
also very female a lot of female
journalists and actors i know did start
to get trolled i never got a single
negative thing but what i did begin to
see was that it was being turned into a
radicalization um
platform
and that
when we now look at things like the
church mosque massacre uh the two
synagogues that got um those massacres
in in america
and that gay bar in america these people
were radicalized online and so twitter
became a platform
that where people were living in echo
chambers and were being radicalized by
just hearing what they wanted to hear
and so i began to realize that if i
stood up i had to stand up to puncture
other people's echo chambers and to
challenge what people were hearing and
using whatever platform i had in order
to
give a different point of view and i do
think that is why i stay on
the health side that is twitter and i
think instagram has become that way i
think those of us that have a voice we
need to stay on those platforms to show
a different alternative long may it
continue that you use your voice because
it's an important one and yours too
thank you um so on a
more positive note uh apart from
merchant of venice what does 2022
mean for you tracy ann well uh it's
interesting i i write a lot of radio
four plays so i'm waiting to i pitched a
couple of radio four plays that i hope
i'm gonna be writing um i'm working with
the royal court at the moment to um do a
piece of work on the back of the whole
um herschel think uh saga another
example of um
unconscious bias against jews
what what saga sorry the uh well the
royal court which is this very
progressive left-wing theater um commit
had a play that was going on with a
character who um they cast an actor who
was known as the nose he was playing um
whilst not being jewish he was playing a
um a money-grabbing
um
money-orientated slightly unscrupulous
elon musk character and his name was
herschel fink
so it was like every jewish trope in the
book and that particular theater had
after um be you know blm and and um
they went they had a massive kind of uh
they they led within the theater
community
a a very big um workshop in
working on prejudice unconscious bias
and racism within their theater
and uh one of the things that was never
mentioned was anti-semitism and the joke
of it is that it led to this
anti-semitic
trope character actor being on their
stage
and everybody was asking how could that
possibly have happened given that it was
flagged up three times in the early
stages of the script that you can't have
a character called herschel think who's
money grabbing and uh a businessman who
is um
is
unscrupulous in his desire for money
played by an actor called the nose you
wouldn't have a character called limpy
limpy wrist lymph wrist uh fairy you
know all that stuff or so um that's been
so i've been working with um our the
artistic director vicky featherstone for
actually quite a while talking about uh
anti-jewish sentiments on the left and
now we're talking about doing a project
next year to to start the dialogue on
that and hopefully if change happens
within the royal court it will filter
down through equity and other theater
associations so that's interesting
um waiting to hear with a couple more tv
things have been recommissioned which
i'm going to be doing and also working
on our merchant of venice which will be
in february
of no january 2023 so that'll be a
year's work and lots of things happening
well i'm very excited for those things
and um i very much intend to come to
merchant of venice and oh gosh you're my
i honestly winston i love your music i
think you're you're a lovely wonderful
man and it's really lovely to meet you
and i think it's great that you're doing
this podcast we have to be able to
tolerate differences of opinion and
diversity of voices otherwise what is
the point what is the point what is the
point we might as well live in a
totalitarian
regime
nuance nuance nuance yeah nuance words a
bit of a nuisance nuance turns out
tracy ann obermann thank you so much for
joining me thank you and um
well
yeah it's been wonderful hearing fun
thank you
[Music]
you